holy crap what are you doing to me
tagashi how can something be so
climactic and yet so anti-climactic at
the same time look I'll admit I was
incredibly naive to get so wildly
excited for the potential of seeing
nobunaka's net abilities I spent far too
much time zeroing in on exactly what I
wanted that I missed the bigger picture
but I'm not at all disappointed because
what we got was in many ways so so much
better I love that luini burst into the
room all flashy like flash flash lots of
big talk and for whatever reason when
the Crescent Moon on his face at all
times he definitely went for dramatic
whereas the Phantom troop just went uh
sort of like a reaction to seeing a fly
buzzing around your room because yeah
you know the fly is mildly annoying but
can I really be bothered to actually do
something about it ah I guess so and
then SWAT which is exactly what Nobunaga
did he took the mildly annoying bug that
is luini or I should say that was luini
and eliminated him with a strike so
casual and unremarkable that it actually
goes full circle and becomes incredibly
hype and completely remarkable I really
like the Precision of nobunago many of
the troop members do have those big
flashy style abilities and to be fair
Nobunaga he might still have one as well
but it's very in keeping with his
Samurai theme to start and end the
battle with a single strike I love it if
this was almost any other Shona manga I
feel like the bulk of this chapter would
have been dedicated to like a big
showcase numanaga fight despite how
irrelevant luini is he would be more or
less a sacrificial vehicle to showcase
the Gloria that is Nobunaga but all
tagashi needs to Showcase it glory is a
single prod in the head and again I
think this really emphasizes that the
troop operate in an entirely different
sphere to the more down to earth style
an end users within the kakin mafia
families the prince is definitely
evolving to a much higher level but the
mafia families right now are all about
you know hand screws and pigeon cuffs
they've got a long way to go it pretty
perfectly set the tone for the
conversation that Henry would have with
hisoka later in the chapter particularly
with the whole admission that look made
we really don't want to fight you we
know that would end badly for us not for
you both the Jiu and the Chara families
know that they are not going to be able
to bring either hisoka or the troop down
so they that whole mission is about
turning the Calamity that is their
existence into their favor before having
both calamities ideally destroy each
other and preserve balance which to be
fair to them is working out so far
because the Phantom troop have decided
that they are going after the hail Lee
family not because of an agreement with
the Chara family not because of any kind
of personal gain but it's because the
mission of the Haley family offends the
troop on a very Primal level you know
their whole philosophy of ah let's
destroy the word for the lulls that's
very counter to what the Phantom troops
stand for and I know it's always a bit
weird to dive into the moral compass of
the Phantom Troupe but everything they
do no matter how horrible always has a
purpose even the curta genocide was
performed for the sake of profit it is
of course despicable and abhorrent but I
suppose at least it's not murder just
for the sake of kill murdering and also
I think that unknowingly luini very much
threatened The Troop when he did his old
leg and destroy the world thing and
revealed that they were going to head
back to the human realm because that
sort of indiscriminate destruction would
obviously come to Target meteor City so
just like when the troop returned to
defend the city against the chimera ants
they now see the Hayley family as a
threat to meteor City if they are left
untouched so the Phantom troop are gonna
touch them touch them with death that
and the Phantom troop generally don't
indulge in chaos just for the sake of
chaos which is a very stark contrast to
hisoka In This Very chapter who admits
that he enjoys that quite a lot Muse
chaos but even at their very worst The
Troop are all about Controlled Chaos so
the values of the troop are actually
very much in line with the Jiu and Chara
families whereas the values of our
battle clown hisok are I think are much
more aligned with the hail the family
the gossip worse did come to worst all
Miranda is going to do is turn the human
realm into some sort of battle world
that Fosters a seemingly endless supply
of powerful nen users for hisoka to
consume if I was hisoka I feel like I
would actually consider teaming up with
Moreno because that's what I as a
selfish horny battle clown would see is
in my best interests especially knowing
that the Haley are about to be targeted
by the troop which isoka does know
because good old honest Henry revealed
all of the plans to him speaking of
Henry's honesty was bizarrely refreshing
because this Arc so far has been all
about secrecy plotting in a war of
information so it was like a much needed
Excel to watch these two separate
parties just speaking bluntly to one
another which went both ways because
hisoka had a very interesting question
for Henry about who he thinks would win
versus the true and Henry basically says
yeah look mate I I'm putting my money on
them which for many antagonists might be
seen was quite insulting like the whole
park are you underestimate my power you
you pigeon man pigeon man but with
hisoka there's another layer to this
because well it sounds weird to say but
this is kind of like his equivalent of
dirty talk oh you think I'd lose tell me
who in particular I'd lose to tell me
about how strong they are and how badly
they're going to beat me in as much
excruciating detail as you can muster
you naughty naughty pigeon boy so
weirdly this is very much playing right
into hisoka's desires Henry is I guess
kind of acting as like a pre-battle
fluffer here and hisoka is a patient man
you will definitely wait for a good time
so I'm not at all surprised with the
idea that hisoka may have taken up in
Henry on his offer also remember that
hisoka for all of his down and dirty
kill murdering is a man who definitely
enjoys his luxury he has very high
standards when it comes to living
quarters cleanliness and of course
fashion so I'm not at all surprised at
an invitation to wait in a vvip room on
tier 1 may pretty seriously tempt him
what I'm more surprised by is that they
immediately tried to put him on tier 1
instead of tier two because remember
tier one that's where all of the princes
are that's where the succession war is
currently taking place so this whole
idea is kind of the equivalent of taking
hisoka off one Battlefield and just
plonking him on another and I cannot
imagine that hisoka would be able to
resist getting involved if he does go to
tier one he's not going to walk into an
orgy of death and just decide not to
participate because there is only so
much Temptation a man can take before
his swing takes over which would start
to make Tier 1 a very nice Nexus point
for the story because if hisoka is there
then he becomes a magnet to attract the
Phantom troop there and then everything
all just comes together exactly how
hisoka likes it at this point I don't
know how likely it is that hisoka makes
it that far and I'm interested in the
Tier 1 pass that Henry Hans hisoka
because in theory any person could use
that and gain access to tier 1. so I'm
almost certainly overthinking this but
it could be more of a plot device to get
handed off to someone else so that they
can reach the princes and I'm bringing
Miranda back into this conversation
because her contagion ability specifies
that killing a prince is worth 50 levels
and again if this was any other series
and I would say that that factor that
factor alone confirms that a healthy
family member will kill a prince because
otherwise why put it in there but this
is Hunter Hunter and the series is just
packed with very interesting but not
necessarily story relevant information
but the existence of this simple past
opens up a lot of doors literally and
narratively because without it tier one
is it's like impossible to access unless
you brute force your way through which
is probably not the greatest of idea
even for the Phantom Troupe but speaking
of levels in Contagion and Miranda this
chapter left me slightly confused with
the hilly section because they spend a
ton of time talking about having someone
develop a counter ability for pigeons
and one of the them says yeah we could
do that but we'll need to get to level
21 first which confuses me because in
the original explanation of Miranda's
heart so it says that upon reaching
level 20 is when the ability manifests
like it's very clear it's not after
gaining 20 levels which would make sense
if one started at level one like it
quite matter of factually States upon
reaching level 20. this is important
because there are two characters here
who are currently level 20s but through
their conversation appear not to have
access to an inability yet so I don't
really know what's happened here it
could be a continuity error it could be
a translation error it could just be a
tagashi retcon but but something is up
in any case doesn't matter it looks like
21 is the new way to go go now and those
two Haley family members are but one
kill away from delicious Nanny goodness
and it shows us something that could be
very potentially dangerous about the
Haley family which is the idea of
keeping people in reserve purposely not
having them Reach a certain level in
order to use them as something of a
general nen toolbox in many ways it's
kind of like nen being applied on an
industrial scale whereas traditional
users are more like your family business
they need to be versatile they need to
be able to tackle many problems but the
Haley family is more of a business
Enterprise consistently training
Executives to open up new branches and
hire new employees to um to destroy the
world if left alone they would almost
certainly become the defining power
holders in the hunter hunter world
because right now all they lack is
experience but if they can make up for
that with numbers teamwork and purposely
constructing certain abilities then that
could be pretty Op with the specific
abilities I actually thought this was
quite short-sighted when I first read it
like the idea that someone has to
manifest a power specifically to deal
with Henry's pigeons because let's say
that works cool the Henry is not a
problem anymore but the issue is that
you're not planning for the versatility
of being able to do anything in the
future and then it just hit me that
doesn't matter they don't need to be
versatile because they have their
industrial nen production strategy they
just need to keep pumping out more and
more product AKA people and abilities
they've got like 200 000 people to feed
on on the Blackwell one so they're not
running out of fuel anytime soon so I
think or at least I hope that the hilly
family have learned their lesson about
you know just starting fight battles
with no plan whatsoever and I hope that
the remaining 21 players are actually
starting to strategize and work together
which it appears that they are the
beginnings of which we see at the end of
the chapter with some nice teamwork
between the Haley old man dude guy and
bakante or bakant I don't know how to
pronounce his name but he is the owner
of the door ability that we're currently
seeing in action as far as I can tell at
the moment it transports whoever steps
through the doorway somewhere else so
really rich Soldier man who did go
through the door he is he's probably
dead by now possibly even killed by one
of the level 20 so they can bring one of
their abilities into existence but Henry
and Wang were not having any of that
crap just briefly though speaking of
Wang he made a face that I never ever
ever want to see again in in anything
ever because that smile is utterly
demonic if I saw that in the real world
I too would be concerned for my imminent
demise and the whole everyone you smile
at dies does actually seem to be a good
predictor because the soldier that Wang
smiled at was the same one who
disappeared and is probably dead it's a
very very interesting ability though the
doorway not the Wang although maybe Wang
Smail is an ability it's a good way to
save money but with the doorway ability
surely it probably has some very
stupidly simple work around like great
we can't step through the doorway but
what if we make a hole in the wall next
to it when it comes down to things
though I'm not entirely sure what Henry
and Wang's plan is here because even if
they get around the door man they're
walking into a den of nen users with not
only unknown abilities but an unknown
number of abilities it really doesn't
seem like the clever and experienced
course of action to take so I'm
wondering if Wang has some sort of
insurance ability that gives these two
the sheer balls they would need to start
a fight with for all they know like two
dozen end users at once or maybe it's
more about identifying cornering and
then calling in your extended
extermination Force including the
Phantom troop what I'm starting to get
more excited for is to see what the
other troop cohorts are up to because
yeah nobunanga's group did agree to hunt
down the Hayley family but there are
like four other parts just roaming
around doing their own thing and given
how quickly things are moving this batch
of chapters might stand a very good
chance of wrapping up the whole Mafia
story and then potentially move back to
the main event with the princes either
way I am stupidly excited so give me
more please